give it up for the new BuzzFeed make
some noise for kids I don't know what it
is
what is k-pop I got nude the bad boy I
have never really heard of it until
Gangnam style the pretty boy it's like
the ninety boyband craze never died but
just turned Korea and Eugene the
building we are gonna be writing the
Korean Wave which includes Korean dramas
Korean film all of Korean culture and
most especially take
[Music]
there are many ways to describe kpop but
I would like to describe it as a
multimedia performance it seems like all
they want to do is party right turquoise
hair ear piercings that go down to here
bibimbap and of course it's party world
cuz mean old dad upstairs doesn't want
any part of it I've like learned a lot
about kpop just through your gene just
rambling at me kpop started gaining
popularity in the late 1990s across Asia
but then once it hit the mid 2000s with
the proliferation of YouTube and online
videos kpop became an international
phenomenon if all of Asia was like a
lunchroom right
South Korea is the cool kids table right
I agree I agree Eugene says that I'm
okay to say that no one will ever get
mad so I'm saying so we're starting with
Girls Generation it's the generation for
girls I know the first thing all the
guys are gonna say is they don't know
why there's so many members there's so
many people already they've shown me at
least a thousand girls so far it doesn't
seem as sexualized as American music
video they can't stop because it's party
time good argument why are they singing
English and it doodlee just said hey on
the screen kpop by design is made to be
successful abroad you know to create
that effective look it's better being
English so that worldwide audience can
really feel they're all like too cute
for camera they're like this to make me
fall in love with them cuz it's working
I wish I had this much fun doing
anything I guess you find the person
that like speaks to you your bias is
your favorite member in a group the
blonde one with long hair cuz it looks
like my wife EXO also produced by SM
Town zach is gonna say that this reminds
me fast and furious cuz he will never
stop talking about bastard arias I was
gonna say Tokyo Drift but we're not in
Japan so wild men appeared like in a
video game one Korean man just becomes
twenty the fact that the men wear makeup
is that something that's prized in
Korean these guys are tougher like an
NSYNC saw them walking down an alley to
be like oh [ __ ] no we gotta go get away
this or mind me like key boys like
similar to American style but like
wearing all the cool things at once
you would get musical style performance
genres it's really taking influence from
a wide range of cultures such as Europe
path
hip-hop R&B it's interesting that like
black cultures can spread even to Korea
how do you transport this many people to
a show just a cage-like alright everyone
in there so get in the cage put the cage
on the truck I thought that he was the
main guy but now they've shifted
positions and now it's the main guy I
can see how everyone can have a favorite
now also here's a thousand articles of
clothing but a mile long what's for a
minute is this on four minutes long
notice that's the group's name that's
the group's name I know the other guys
are gonna go crazy when they hear this
track it's like this is hardest I this
is great
[Music]
this is like a Missy Elliott were Korean
they constantly are walking happy with
their but how does it feel Korea I think
kpop videos tend to be one of three C's
you're either cool Q or crazy but the
best kpop videos intend to be a mixture
of all three all of these music videos
have insane production value like in
America we don't spend money on music
videos anymore with like very few
exceptions in Korea they are throwing
all the money at music videos and that
is awesome
Corman is just trying to give me a boner
and that's working they it's there's a
lot of us let's be serious though Game
of Thrones seven how many members are in
your band we got seven pretty good joke
right it's in like a little girl's
bedroom so weird Bennet's to start
anything with I feel uncomfortable and I
don't know what's happening I think it's
all a metaphor for drugs so they're very
bright and cheerful get out of her
cereal she has to eat that this
definitely feels like one direction it's
like Toy Story with hot Korean guys when
I was a little kid I was considered as
the ugliest person that anyone's ever
seen and now people are thirsting after
Korean guys and girls I just fall in
love with him comes with melodies
anything I absolutely love that how you
is bringing Asian faces into popular
media worldwide
wow there's good
look like my wife he makes me feel the
way my wife thank you stop trying to be
sexy she is eight she's eight years old
sir I'm over this shake it by soos
collar I assume that you have to say it
sort of a Russian accent I would
legitimately put up a poster of these
girls on my room oh we were focusing on
like dark and gritty they're like [ __ ]
that was gonna be colors and fun early
2000s Trapper Keeper grunge vibe there's
a lot of shaking your butt slightly in
these music videos you know the one
thing I really like about sISTAR is that
they're challenging some standards of
Korean beauty by being tan they're
rolling their hips in the classroom they
still want to get the answer right
because education is important even the
South Korean presidential office set of
national branding campaign to really use
kpop to improve nation soft power
there's a hockey team on a football
field whatever I hope this is better
than the Big Bang Theory you would hear
this beat in a gay club at 3:00 and then
you would get time this is 50 million
views man there's some big bands that I
am completely unaware of oh there's no
one's wearing a shirt now they're
cowboys and astronauts huh these things
happen so quickly when I was talking
about the astronaut I missed something
else entirely
you have a very easily identifiable
aesthetic are so many different segments
that you have to watch at least 10 times
to figure out what's going on and that
naturally increases the number of
viewing it feels like an episode of
Doctor Who on acid now it's like she's
crazy and there's guns it's basically
like eight music videos split up where
like each person gets his own half a
million dollars say there's a certain
list of artists that I would introduce
non-koreans to first and I think big
bangs near the top of that because they
have
oh okay I get what this song is about
now the poor sounds nothing like the
verses bang bang oh my god
I'm feeling this music his name is
g-dragon
his name is g-dragon is his name top
because it just wears giant top at the
one I like the best is the one that
looks at me with a sultry eye mr. dragon
your seat is right over here so you
don't have to be Korean to enjoy Korean
culture Korean culture is dynamic
exciting and there's something for
everyone I'm really impressed I'm
speechless really it's better than our
pop is I can dug it up a lose/lose stuff
all the time
all our pop music is to sentiment we
need more fun in it I've never been more
excited for a try guys series because as
a Korean I get to introduce the other
guys to my culture kpop stuff is like
the capital in The Hunger Games like
ruffles and they're like Super Junior me
more but they say that in Korean